Well. Well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Instances.
They're
loud. Yeah, I know. I
just told you that. Told.
Did you turn it down for me
please, please, please, please.
All right, we're good. Thanks.
Yeah, thanks Jean. Need
cry about that. All right.
And now your diaper would be
exceptionally photo exaggeration. Why?
It's the truth. All right. You
got to turn your bell tones down.
Oh Man. It'll ridiculous. Rich. Um,
we did it episode 400 crazy.
I can't believe we've found a way to
talk about a farting poop pooping.
You sound like one of the critics.
It's the only thing we do here.
It's amazing though, isn't it? I mean,
yeah, there's a lot of stuff that goes on
for a four.
I remember that happy 400th anniversary.
That'd be 400 a smurf or re before
hundred. I can't believe it.
When we started this silly show in
our house in silver lakes. Yeah.
I remember we sat at the kitchen table,
I'll never forget this,
and we had the discussion over
what to name our new podcast.
Yeah. And we, I forget the other
candidates, but it was basically,
what's the dumbest thing we could
call a podcast? And we were like, oh,
that's your mom's house.
Where are you going to your mom's house?
Your Mom's house? Yeah.
Yeah. Isn't that silly?
It's so silly. It's so silly. I remember
writing down in a, an old joke book,
um,
some dumb line about opening a restaurant
called your mom's house so that you
could say that there's somebody like,
just for the purpose of that. Yeah.
It's mom's house. It's your mom's
house. But here we are, 400 episodes.
I can't believe I'm living in the house.
That Brown Bill Brown talk bill.
The guy that used to
work in this space made beautiful music.
We make, we make different
types of music here. Yeah. Yep.
Different stuff. Same strokes, different
say for everyone. Everyone's the same.
So excited though.
Yeah.
What's your favorite thing we've ever
done on the show or you think it's for
after the break here? After we,
oh yeah. You know what though?
I'm still caught up on their brown story
because you started to tell me a brown
story and then I was like,
wait, save it, save it.
And now I'm still thinking about
courses. What happened? Yeah,
they're going about it.
You ready to do this? Yeah.
Cause I have a good story for you
to. Hmm. Okay. Yeah. Can't wait.
There you go. Let's get it
started. Episode Mute my mom.
Episode 400 of your mom's house muted.
Why is he gay?
Full of feed me.
We are for a man to be okay with his feet.
May licking his AA during sex.
Yeah,
she fuck. What's your
herd? Beach. I'm as local
is Randy.
Don't bring anyone loving to live.
Well,
go to your mom's house with Tom.
Christina.
Wow.
400 episodes of that opening song.
It never gets old to me.
I still like it on songs. You get
tired. I don't want to, I mean,
you're tired of it. Great. Sound at your
mom's house. Intro music. I like it.
I should have beta. I love the, I love the
intro. Yeah, the sweet guitar licks like,
Oh yeah, it's absurd. Every, oh
my God, I almost just my uncle.
Okay.
Toilet paper. No, I can use this. Uh,
no, probably. Go ahead and do the paper.
You get it? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I
could see where this is going to go. Okay.
Fan for a minute.
Okay. So yeah, I love, I can,
I think I've told it on
another podcast before,
but Ryan match the match man down
in breast balls, beach, Florida.
He created that opening song and a
bunch of like the segment intros and I
remember sending him clips and being like,
here's Mr t right,
here's coach ice and but you know,
left it to him to be creative with it.
Yeah.
And he came up with that.
Well, cause we at the time we're playing
that Mr t clip, that was a silly one.
Like everyone, anything that said,
mom, your mom yeah. Treats your mother.
Right. Your mother, right.
Oh he came on his mind because there were
like your mama's so fat. And he's like,
Whoa, whoa. Don't get anybody's
mother into this. The stupid video.
And then it went to your mom
and the fuck is stands. Yeah.
And then there was, uh, who was Randy
that had nothing that looks like,
you know what that looks like.
That's your coffee.
But the, uh, uh,
Randy was Randy,
that was hall of fame.
Tight end for the Baltimore Colts.
Yeah. Um, okay. Name. I can't,
I just drew a blank on his name.
Um, but he had dementia and, um,
let me look, let me look it up.
Who it is so I can,
I can tie it in
kind of a gay name for a position and
foosball, isn't it? Yeah, the tight end.
Yeah. John Mackey, that's how it works.
John Mackey and he had dementia
and then his wife and he,
he were being interviewed. Yeah. And
then, uh, and then the guy was like, well,
what's it like living with him
and isn't she? And then she, yeah,
it's really sad actually. It's one of the
saddest things, right? Because she goes,
you know, we repeat the conversations
and when he asked me like, you know,
when are we leaving?
I tell him, uh, Randy,
who's a made up name of a mechanic,
he's working on the car.
And then, you know, that puts them off
for a while and then he asks again like,
are you ready to go?
And then they cut to the interviewer
and the interviewer goes, John,
is Randy working on the car right now?
I could try to like get in on the thing.
And then John Goes, Ooh, is Randy?
That's another hilarious scene.
Just like Stevie's hilarious. Right?
Well you think that's hilarious to,
and he's really funny and they
are making fun of me really dark.
You're making fun of me. It is dark,
but Stevie doesn't have dementia.
He's moderately touched, but
he's tired. Yeah, Stevie special.
But he's not retarded. Yeah,
Stevie's got a promise with you.
He's got a lot of problems and we really,
I really liked that one.
And then I really liked the Todd
Phillips. He enjoying? Yeah,
no, she's the smartest one
in the whole documentary.
She's the Yoda.
She's like,
you shouldn't be with someone
that abuses you and you're like,
how does this bitch? No, she's the only
one that says anything remotely normal
that's in the bed and is even
more disabled than her. Right.
Has even greater insight. Remember?
No, I don't remember what she said,
but I do remember her friend was like,
oh, right, right. The he
needs a piece of shit. Right.
She's the only one that's flat out
like, look, see, he's a shit head. Yeah.
That guy's a real shit bird. You need
to get out, man. He smoked. He gets mad.
They get over it.
I was like real life stuff.
Later on down the road
near the road gets mad.
He always pluralizes is the wrong word.
They were changes.
People change it.
See, he always gets the plural
round. Yeah. I like when he's all,
people call me snake cause I ain't
afraid of them and nobody calls. Yeah.
When you woke up to a rattlesnake,
do you stand there?
Do you run like hell, Fintech
a chance again, better not run.
I was like,
do I take a chance?
Then people in take a chance again stabbed
in the back again. Oh, well. All right,
well I guess that's not
the people call me snake,
but we'll see you get the
point. Hello problems. Oh,
here we go. Here we go. Yeah.
That's why I get my name's snake for him.
I ain't afraid of him.
Never has been except whereas a kid.
Right.
That'd be a big part of when you, that
would negate your first statement. Right.
Never been afraid of him set for the first
12 years of my life philosophy. Yeah.
Yeah.
Cause you never implies never either.
Never or it has been symbolic logic does.
You don't even need to take it.
He's wrote that fucking bug, right? Yeah.
Suck the Venn diagrams that those
types of things are a big part of, uh,
the culture these days. The statements
that don't make sense. Untruth.
Yeah.
They're a big part of the news.
I think we're all kind of
becoming experts on things.
It makes sense and no
nonsense. It is, can I,
and I know everyone's buying
1984 the George Orwell bug,
but it is double plus good. It's called
new speak in that book. And it's,
there's totally an,
an entirely new lexicon and its new
speak and it's jibberish and it's double
plus good. I'd rather focus on whether
eating ass is gay or not. Agreed.
And we get to the important stuff.
This lady makes a great
point and it's something I,
I really wanted to highlight this.
Everyone was like,
what's special about episode
400? What's going to go on? Well,
this clip was sent in and
it made me think of what,
what would be a better,
um,
celebration of this podcast?
Then if legitimately in episode 400,
we can get you to open up your eyes,
open up your heart, open up your mind,
and ultimately open up your mouth to lick
my rear end. It's never going to have,
can you just, but can you just
for this episode, for the episode,
can you entertain the idea just for this
podcast? Entertain the idea. I mean,
I guess I owe it to the listeners.
There we go for 400.
And I see just for you doing that,
I think that, uh, there's like, uh,
a need to celebrate that you just,
you just scared.
Just that you're entertaining the idea.
[inaudible]
those are celebration horns and explosions
in the morning crew.
I didn't even see that. But listen, first
of all, can I ask you a real question?
Is this woman going to threaten our
marriage? Swipey number two, right here.
Am I looking down the barrel of
the next Mrs [inaudible] Gora uh,
this is just, you know what?
Somebody that I want you to mirror,
it's not going to expose us to grow up,
but I want you to be like, oh, I could,
I could be just like this. Just
listen. I know you're big on logic.
You're big on philosophy. Just knows. She
has to say. Okay. That's all I'm asking.
I tell you what I'm afraid of. What your
asshole pacifically what? It's the heat.
Yeah. So hot down there, the
heat and the sweat and the hair.
That's more than one thing. And the
smells. Jeez. Why here? Your dumps?
They don't sound good. I can only
deduce that the smells aren't good.
I, I've heard you shit.
I can't, I can't unknow
it is,
it's a nice man.
But do you think you could get it sterile
enough that I won't contract some kind
of, um, and ultimately disease?
Absolutely sterile. Let's,
let's jump on this journey together.
I'm holding your hand.
Let's go through this
whole thing and see if, uh,
this lady couldn't convince you otherwise.
Why is he gay?
Full of fee meal for a,
for a man to be okay with his
female licking his ass during sex.
She fuck with your herbage I'm as local
liquor. So right away she's
saying that that's what she does.
Now let's see why she does it.
Yeah.
My Nigga,
we let me lick his ass
the shit out of his ass.
Like niggas eat pizza.
Okay,
so right away you know that there's
ladies out there that go really hardcore
into it.
He's not saying like that.
She goes right to those
women are mentally unstable.
She seems fine.
She seems really sweet.
I actually really enjoy her
demeanor and I like her.
I'm just not convinced she's right in
the head. I don't know her well enough,
but I don't think that's normal.
There's an interesting statement.
Not that I had this fear anyways,
but just I'm saying she has,
how long think is gay horse not a between
a man and a fee meall right to go home
because it's between a man and a female.
I agree that's
big toe and that, and that was
never an issue. Obviously for us.
We didn't say this was gay,
but that speaks to a certain segment
of the population that does have that
apprehension.
So I just think that's a very soon
offended personally the use of pronouns.
Like she didn't, she wasn't inclusive
of all the different binary genders.
So yeah, I mean what is a female? What
does mail, what is she talking about?
So it's a,
it's disrespectful firstly,
but doing it is, it's just like
the gate. It's just like, but yes,
to your point,
I don't think she's right and I have never
heard it actually expressed that way.
She said it perfectly. She's speaking
actually to something different.
She speaking, telling men who don't want
to try it, she's not speaking to me.
Obviously I'm back. I'm on my hands
and knees. I'm praying the rosary.
I'm making dedications to it,
but their rosary speaking to
you sound like your mother
told me, well, what's in it for me?
What's in it for me? Let's go there.
Remember the dog food ring? Yeah.
What's in it? Well, what do you need?
What do you want? Some material
thing. I mean absolutely.
I thought just knowing that you're
blowing your husband's mind and giving him
great pleasure to be enough.
Not only works when you're dating,
that's not the same. There's married
kid. It doesn't work that way.
Really disappointing on,
let me just think about it.
I mean I want to go to Tahiti.
That's a bucket list thing. Yeah,
but we're not going to do that right now.
Well,
when Ellis is a little older
and we're in the overlooking
the water, the one that
I want to stay in. Yeah.
That's when the ass lick will take place,
so I got to put off an ass lick
for possibly a decade. Come on.
It's hot.
Are there and to eat.
That's the problem is that I'm actually
making more problems for myself just to,
come on, let me just think here. All
right. What I would like, let's be real.
Let's be real. Let's be price tag
on this, uh, on this sexual act.
Let me think about what I really
want in life. I mean, I, like I said,
I want to go on trips. I like trips
and I'm not terribly. All right.
What about a materialistic?
I mean, and also by the way,
if you agree to terms on this, you can't
just go, Huh? That'd be like, I did it.
I did it. I did it. Map so scared.
You got a barrier, you know?
Good. What'd you wax it? Yeah.
You promise. Hairless. Hairless.
I'm afraid. Honestly. I'm afraid of
the hair and the smell that hair traps.
Let's keep it honest and,
and the heat,
there's a lot of heat because I put my
finger in there. Playfully. Not In there,
but are in the area. Yeah. Pretend
spread your cheeks and it's hot.
It's so sweaty. It's
like a jungle. Um, okay.
I'll get it waxed while
you're gone this weekend.
You're going to come back to a
hairless ass on stuff for my birthday.
It a birthday treat, June 18th.
Oh, it's my special birthday. Yeah.
I get to lick your ass. How did
that happen? It's also father's day.
That's how that happened.
That's what's going on. Let
me think. What do you think?
It's waxed.
Okay, so that's out of the car.
That's fine. Mm. Signed off on that.
What do you really want to Haiti?
I mean,
come on Fiji or weekend to loom.
I want to go stairwells on the beach and
stare at Shit. It's gotta be somewhere.
We're going to bring the boy right now.
Oh God. It's no vacation at all. Is it?
I know.
How about a day where you watch the kid
and I go stare at the beach. Yeah, fine.
I want to a Malibu or something.
Yeah. Check in some nice
place alone. She's fine.
But I mean, we're talking like
squat over your face squat
and you just, and you do just
uh, yeah. Tongues, worlds.
I didn't agree to that
first part of the deal. No,
but I don't trust that your thighs can,
I think you're going to smother
me if you do it that way.
Hold my asshole's going to but not,
I don't trust that you will.
You will respect me enough to not smoke.
You're your joker. You're mean
mean you'll smother me. No,
I'll just, I'll just
no, no. Stand over you.
I'll just kind of ease into it.
No, my ass. My ass. Yeah,
no singing. Do you like what about I,
we do the, we do the Dai Dai change.
That's the only way I would do it.
The spread. Oh okay. Yeah. The pan.
While your rebate, remember laying
on my back. I pulled my legs up.
You changed my diet and
you got to town. Yeah,
I go to town. Let me listen to what she
has. I'm just not an end to this dude.
I'm really not into that.
I'm trying. I'm really,
I'm really trying to wrap my brain.
Yes,
you got to be honest fellows.
It feel good to hear your a sleep.
Cause I had my [inaudible] bad
few in shit feel real good to me.
So I know that she feel good to y'all
and y'all just uncomfortable because she
feel good and he seen your Aas
and you know that's a gay spot.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm not worried about the gay stuff.
Yeah. I don't think anything between man,
I who cares. Even if it
were, I'm just honestly,
I'm honestly afraid of bacteria
and you know that I am,
I'm afraid of vomiting. No, no.
I'm talking about ingesting
fecal matter. I'm a very, uh,
you know, against poopy in
my mouth. Full inspection.
If you can't get that on an eyeball
and there's just germs, bacteria,
let's have fucking doctors write in and
tell us how many fecal to oral cases
they've seen. You'd get worms, parasites.
So that's the major concern. Yes.
Honestly, it's sickness that
terrifies me. I mean, Shit, man.
That's how you get like hepatitis,
when you go to other countries, it's,
it's fecal matter in food.
He's going to let me live with this
request.
Burning too
bubbly. Just say, ah, yeah, I'm afraid
we're just going to have to not.
You just almost signed up for, I
didn't sign it. I'm afraid. Listen,
if we have doctors write in,
if somebody can assure me in the medical
community listening that it would not
result in me getting hepatitis or
some horrific disease, then yeah,
go ahead. Courses. If he
tell me it's not possible.
So it's dirty fecal. It is. Yours
is, no, I'm saying after a shower,
stop saying like you're like dirty.
It's not, it's not finishing it.
That's what I don't care is why? Because
I get leaky, but all the time I shit,
this is why I started brown to shower
because I make a brown and then I wipe,
wipe, wipe and the Brown keeps
coming and that's when I had
good to hear your ASD
speaking as somebody whose finger
doesn't close after childbirth. Alright.
This is just dumb at this point.
It's not done. It's a valid point.
It's bacteria that you shouldn't put
in your mouth. All right. I mean,
aren't you afraid of that?
No. No. I think you're,
the whole thing is nonsense. I think
you should lick fiefs. Buttle no,
I'm going to have him look mine.
Cause can we talk about the Brown story?
I'm dying to hear the end
of it. All right. All right.
Episode 400.
I love this intro.
Really talent.
Talent. Yeah, of course.
I didn't production plop
sounds and the audio cut out. Yeah,
sure. Um, okay. So let's start.
Walk me through the beginning.
So, oh well first of all,
I just had an amazing weekend.
Amazing, amazing, amazing.
I started in Tux in Arizona,
805 and they were like guys just
getting started as a springtime.
And uh, but uh, son Pusan
Yeah. Pusan Arizona,
uh, brought Josh Potter with
me. Very funny. Super Funny Guy.
Sweet guy too. Yeah. Really great guy.
He, he, he killed it. Great
shows. So we started there.
We did the reality theater. So much
fun. Thank you everybody that came out.
I had an absolute fucking blast there.
Then the next day we went to Reno.
You know,
I'm feeling like you're kind of glazing
over the important points of the story.
What were you eating?
How frequently we went to El Charro.
Mexican steakhouse. Sounded like
your recipe for El bub blasting.
Yeah. Yeah, but no, I mean
it was delicious. You know,
I just had meat and veggies.
That's what I, that's how I get down.
Yeah. Um, and then I see, by the way,
I worked out before every
single show. Okay, good.
That's what I do as part of my routine.
I mean, the hotel shows him three hours.
Cool. I'm going to go to the gym. I spend
about an hour there, then come back,
shower, get ready for the show. So
that exhausts me. It doesn't, it,
that makes me more tired. I
add the ad, make me angrier.
It makes me awake and alert
and I feel like, Oh yeah,
I drank coffee around five.
I get jacked.
I take a couple of doubts and I
watch a Netflix. Oh, see I can't,
I can't do it that way. I can't lay down
and do a show I don't like, Oh yeah,
I can lay down in the green room and
then get up on stage. I go from zero.
It makes me feel more tired. It's
just the way I am. Like if I'm,
if I'm laying around, I feel more
tired. If I'm active, I feel more alert.
I always feel like when we're done
making fitness, I'd have to take a nap.
I'm just tired. Interesting.
Now the only time yeah,
that I would feel that way is if it's
like balls to the wall, you know,
blow out workout. But I
don't do that. I try to do,
do moderate so that like, oh,
heart rates up, I'm sweating,
but I don't try to go like, um,
you know, super high intensity.
Yeah. Anyway, um,
so after that a reno, which I think I'd
been to reno, but I don't even remember,
but we went to Reno to
the Grand Sierra resort.
Such a beautiful, beautiful
theater. The Grand Theater,
they remodeled it. Unbelievable. I mean,
just such a gorgeous venue.
Amazing history.
They had I guess as this is one of the
old school reno casinos that has been
remodeled. Sinatra had
your favorite. Yeah.
The greatest singer of all time
up, up, up, up. Look at that
time at the bar, hooked up, up.
Uh,
those legs are going on for days,
so, Oh God, he
scaled the Bup, bup, not thinking anyway.
He didn't want it has the biggest stage,
like actual physical square
footage of stage in the world.
Yeah.
And they said it that stage.
Well the stage that you're on has
the curtain dropped and is enormous.
If you go behind the curtain,
there's a plane, there's Nana's, um,
just they land a plane on,
no, no, it's a pro. It's a prop for
a, for a play that ran for 35 years,
but it's a full size plane.
It looks like a bike parked in someone's
backyard because that's how big
backstage, it's not even, it doesn't
even stand out. Like whoa. It's just,
it goes on and on and on.
It's an enormous backstage.
It's like an airfield hanger.
It's just huge. See they
have like, they're like, oh,
that was part of a play that
stopped running 10 years ago,
but we just left it here and
it's this enormous like fountain,
like structure and they're like, we
just don't know where to put it anyways.
Then you see like a shed,
it looks like a, um,
like a storage unit and
it's all locked up and you,
you don't even pay attention to
it. I'm like, you want to see this?
And they open it. They're like, this
was Frank Sinatra's room. And I'm like,
what do you mean his room?
And they go,
well he didn't want to stay in the
hotel and have to walk over here.
So they built him
a room,
Jeez.
Backstage so that he could eat,
sleep congregate.
Right.
And then walk out and be like
basically on state. Crazy.
I mean I can get that.
Imagine being Frank Sinatra famous and
walking through the hotel every night.
Well I thought it was because
people would, as I said, Oh yeah,
cause he doesn't want people to see
them. And they were like, no, no,
because he didn't want to walk
that far. Huh? Oh, I, yeah,
I thought it was the same thing.
Yeah.
Him being so famous that people would
stop him. But yeah, I guess not. Yeah,
it was just a lazy piece of Shit. Yeah.
They didn't phrase it that way. But yeah,
I think he just wanted the convenience
of it. Like, when's the show? Cool.
I'll be here. I'll tell you that.
That gives me so much anxiety. I,
there's one club and I won't say
where because I don't want to
let everybody know where the comic sleeps,
but there's one club where
they put you up in the hotel.
The club is in the hotel, and then
your room is right behind the stage.
There's a few of those terrible,
really weird. Emotionally,
mentally you need a break. They
Cooper's not bad. The comedy mix,
because that's in the basement
of the hotel, but it's a
nice hotel, you know? Oh,
so we, yeah, but it's not,
I'm talking about this club.
They literally put you in the room that
if you open the back door to the stage,
there's your room. Oh No, I don't like
that. I don't know. I did that one. Yeah,
you have.
I have. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now I remember too. Yeah.
I did that once and then they
asked me back and I go, guess what?
I'm not saying there though. Not saying
they're able to revise that deal. Well,
and what's crazy is that like really
famous people have done that room and have
stayed in that room and you're like,
wait,
how is that possible that that room
is also the green room? They're like,
just go to your room.
Yeah. Cause there isn't
an agreement. It's right.
There's like a steps to the
stage and then it's weird.
Like this is not how show business
works at all. Yeah. Pretty funny.
But let's get to the importance
that, I mean we'll, hold on,
let me finish telling you the story man.
And now I'm chomping at the bad
amazing crowd in Reno.
I mean fucking crazy.
It was 2,600 people in Reno.
Yeah.
I didn't know that many people
lived in Reno. It was crazy.
And then last night the Chenga,
I did a Spanish word for pussy.
That's right. We, let me, let me look.
Your partner, what is Penecci
Che? Yeah, that's different.
But it sounds like by Chang is actually
in the tribal name of that trial.
In other words,
they are something,
the Chang is the Harry
Pachangas. Yeah. So,
but again,
another beautiful place.
They really have poured a
ton of money into that place.
I've seen the commercials, I've never been
there really nice. It's really nice. Um,
and uh, in a really, really great
crowd. And uh, among, uh, Maria came,
she was that last night. I made fun
of her from the stage, you know,
third, my show. First thing when
I see up, she was like, oh, I saw,
yeah, talk like I talk like that and I go,
well, you do as you're doing right now.
She's like, I don't go like,
aw, aw, you kind of do,
it looks like really fast, like
really fast. But I don't go like, ah,
she says I do it, but then I point
out, I don't just say, you go,
ah, I just said, you're like, ah,
I'll have to try to smoke a wet.
Which she's like, I didn't say it.
Like, ah. Anyway, she was there.
My cousin Janette was there, both of
their spouses. We had a great night.
Uh,
then we went out for dinner afterwards and
had a great time. So anyways,
this morning, normally if, if, uh,
if they hadn't been there
right after the show,
I would've gotten my car and be like,
I'm just gonna go back home. Right.
Because it's about a two hour drive,
maybe a little more.
But since my sister's in town, which is
rare, I go, well, we should have dinner.
It's like I'm going to spend the night
because then, then it gets too late.
So I get up this morning and I'm like,
I got to get back.
We got to do the podcast, you
know, there's things to do.
So I'm in the room and I'm like, when
is this shit going to come? Hold on man.
I'm finally, finally get to the part
of the story that I care about. Okay.
You said you had hotel coffee now is
this, no, no, no. You're jumping ahead.
Jumping ahead. Before I get there
and you're saying let's go back.
I haven't even gotten there yet.
So
I'm sitting there and I'm
thinking, stupid. Huh?
I'm thinking I got to get
in my car and get back home.
When is this dump going
to? I know it's a, I go,
is it going to come during this drive
and ruined this drive from worse to is?
Yeah. So then I go, should I try
to like, it's not ready to come.
Should I try to force a dump out? You
know, like, no, I know what I'll do.
I'll make a little hotel room coffee
and see if I can get the engine started.
You know? So I brew it. I'm putting stuff
in my bag and packing. I'm Kinda like,
and then you know, you're thinking like,
ah, how long is this drive going to take?
Right. I have a sip and I'm like, you
know, I could sit here for 15 minutes,
drink this coffee and probably do this,
but I don't want to wait 15 minutes
right now and it's not ready.
No Ma marriage. Before we continue,
may I give you my travel tip?
And this is for the listeners,
whenever you're traveling,
go buy the Starbucks instant coffee.
Go to Starbucks before your trip
or aren't Amazon using our banner,
your mom's House podcast out and you buy
the instant packets. I'm telling you,
that shit is white.
It's brown lightning,
you'll drink that and you're going to
shit that shit that doesn't make you shit.
Nothing. Well, and that's great
for travel but, but continue.
I should've given you some,
that's what I was trying to say.
I feel badly that did not.
So anyway,
so you're like, do I stay, sit
here, finish this cup. Yeah.
Now did you finish the whole no, no, no.
Is, that's what I'm saying. So I
have a sip and I go, oh my God.
Like I can feel the beginning
like the oil getting grease,
but it's not ready or do I go cause I
want to go, I want to get back. Right.
So I just go, fuck it. I'm
leaving. I go downstairs,
get the car and here's a big decision.
I wasn't even a decision.
It's actually kind of made for me.
I got to put gas in the car and I go,
is there a Starbucks or a coffee bean
or someplace to get coffee for my drive
back?
I don't see one for the
first half hour of the drive,
which is really annoying.
But then I realize that's actually doing
me a favor because if I were drinking
it,
I would have to dump.
So I actually right now I'm like,
I don't know,
10 minutes from the house, two hours
plus into this drive. And I realize, oh,
it's a good thing I didn't find coffee.
So I do find someone, I'm like uh,
right around the corner from the house
and as soon as I get in the house I say
hi to you.
Um,
I have a couple sips of coffee and then
boom, ready to go. And it was like a
nice for,
that's interesting.
What's interesting is that when I travel
and I go to Barre stocks and I get a
double tall a soy latte. Yeah.
It doesn't make me shit anymore.
It's not strong enough. Oh
yeah. Cause that's, that's
mostly soy milk. Double Tall.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. It
doesn't make me Brown. You got to,
you got to go for the fire man.
You've got to get some of this s espresso.
Espresso. Yeah. Interesting.
Interesting. Um, can I,
can I share my story with you
please? Sure. I mean you just go, oh,
I'm moving like no,
nobody else has a brown story to share
as long as no one else is talking. Yeah.
Oh well, okay. So anyways,
last night I made eggplant and I ate
a whole almost the whole egg plant to
myself.
Yeah.
And then I went to sleep and I
didn't have any farts all night,
which for sure is like
excellent. Yeah. Yeah.
Eggplants make me Fart so bad.
Yeah, I know that for sure.
And I didn't hit any kind of Florence
and I was like concerned a little like
what does that mean? It doesn't mean
that like can you make your body immune?
I don't think so. The farts? Yeah. No,
cause I eat Brussel sprouts now and I
don't really get as many fights as I used
to in the beginning. So
anyways, no, I'm serious.
I think you can build a resistance to
the food that gives you the farts and you
get less parts over time. Yeah.
So I'm having like no farts.
And then this morning I drank my coffee
and I took the biggest shit of my life.
I mean it was so much and I thought,
isn't that weird though that I didn't
have any like very good, very good. Yay.
But I didn't have any warning
shots like there was not nothing.
What's your theory on this?
Cause it sounds really interesting so far.
That's your, uh, my theory
is that I've grown it.
You can build an immunity to flu.
You're not having,
you're not having that every
day. Eggplant. So not every day,
but I've had it enough to
build an immunity. You know,
it's like when you take a little
bit of the poison every day,
your body builds an immunity
to it. Interesting. I don't
know if I believe that,
but I do know,
I believe that in theory,
I still believe that that theory applies
here cause it's not like you're like
constantly eating this stuff for you
to build the immunity. I did enough.
You think? So I do a Brussels
sprouts to aunt dried apricot.
It's those main used to make me feel
really bad and they really don't do that
anymore.
Okay. I'm in the shed. Okay.
Yeah, there's a reason.
Well,
I think I found out her reason.
That's why she's in the shed cheese thing.
I have a bunch of girls here.
If you see my writing other sites,
you'll see there's suddenly
all kinds of pictures of,
of me and other girls and video's going
to be showing up very short. Other girls.
Yeah, we're taking videos
and problems. Yeah.
Hear the rooster crowing.
Um,
what would it have taken for you to go
down this path you think? Not a lot.
Like how close could you
have been to like, oh,
there's videos on my site and you're
just like, they're going to be up soon.
It would be in some other girls.
I have gas and then you turn it on,
you fart into a camera.
2009 could have happened.
He thinks that like had nothing
picked out for us. Yeah.
I mean we were looking at us. I wouldn't
be with you if this was going on.
I'm saying you're alone for
sure. He wouldn't support
me and my business venture.
Definitely not. No, no, no. Well, I mean
2008 where we were at our brokenness,
we have no money. Nearly married.
I mean, this is easy money, dude.
As far as I'm concerned,
no, I think, no dude, easy
not married to this.
My mock this on our podcast.
I'm not married to it.
You know how fucking I could do this
and let's say 2007 instead of getting
engaged,
we break up a year later.
Are you in a shed farting in my camera?
Yes.
Possibly. Because look,
when I married you,
I mean I had just transitioned
into being a fulltime fee track.
I had no money and I leaned
in on you and you know, we,
because of you, it been
like, hey, pretty girl.
You're thinking about other ways to make
money and you're like, oh my God, no.
Would you ever come by my shed this week?
And uh,
he,
he's,
he plenty of eggplant before you go over
there where your Pajama bottoms too.
That's a weird choice. The
Pajama bottoms, she eats veggies.
Yeah,
that was all swollen. So
yesterday I thought vegetables,
some rooster
is the best idea.
She's a Christian, at least.
Did you see her cross? Yeah.
Ah, it's such just mailing
$100 to that far. I know.
How much do you think she can,
but she's in the veggies just
like you blonde big cans. Yeah.
Just like you healthy diet guys.
I could do. I could so do
it. It's really not a big,
okay.
I'm going to go try to go
back to the party and put
half that and pictures of it.
Yeah. I might be back though
because I don't think this is real.
All of the cheeks got up on her tippy toes
for that one. She got up. She was like,
oh,
I wouldn't do it that way.
I would make mine more playful
the way king ass rapper does.
I create more scenarios,
more oopsies,
different locations.
The shed is not exciting to the viewer.
I don't like to shed that. She's
out there making that like this. Uh,
yeah.
I don't like the shed aspect of it.
I know.
I like that.
That would be a little more fun about it.
Oh my [inaudible].
Yeah,
I know this. Can you
believe it? Oh my gosh.
I'm so embarrassed
now and a response. We came up with
a very serious topic discussion.
We normally don't get the
serious on the show. Uh,
but we were wondering what do you
call it when you have to dump,
but only a fart comes out and we,
how's that
big,
big conversation started last week.
Um, a number of them
came in here. Oh wait,
can I glean from Twitter?
Sure, sure. Okay.
At Real Big Kong writes a no shit.
But a fart should be called a
Chanel shit and nope. Combo.
All right, so again, just to make
people clear on this shore, uh,
we've said that when you think you're
going to fart and you and you should,
it's a shark. What about when you think
you're going to shit and you only fart?
Why isn't there a word for it?
Right, right, right. Okay. Uh,
this one is from at Garel be dumped.
Fake Ghost Shit.
Counter Shit.
Charlatan. I like that one. That one
a lot. Or imposter. That's funny.
I'll strong suggestions.
I like counter shit or charlatan.
I'm kind of leaning towards short 10.
Booster boosters are funny. Uh, okay.
Just watch the latest episode. Mommy's,
this is from at secret moves MMA.
What if the opposite of sharp was far,
which also sounds like farce.
Yeah, I mean, that's a suggestion.
A food. I heard that
one. That's not bad. Um,
someone said there's a, uh,
seduce a pseudo deuce. I said
yes. At Chase Leopard rights. Uh,
when you think you're going to shit
and you only Fart, it's a Charlotte.
It was pretty good. Yeah. Somebody
said there's no word combos for this.
It's just simply a solid fart.
I just a disappointment.
A Brown downer. Oh, I like a brick.
Came in Rachel from Portland. Okay.
When range. Yeah. Somebody
calls it a Macbeth.
I'm like that.
Yeah.
It is a tale told by an idiot full
of sound and fury signifying nothing.
Very good like that. Uh, moms,
when you go to take your shit only turns
out to be a tutor. It's called a shoot.
Ah. Um, ah, uh,
Tibbs said it's a poltergeist.
Wow. I like that one a lot.
Octo poos him spirit poop. Yeah. Uh,
this one said you're not taking
this shit home and you're frowning.
Fart failed was brown frown.
Yeah.
That's Kate and the
resident Fart gentlemen.
Thank you for all your [inaudible]
where I'm leaning. Yeah,
I like pull pools or geist a lot.
Charlatan. And I like
imposter. That's really good.
It's really hot in here too,
cause it's like the 90 outside today.
Yeah. So I'm in a room, it's
fed, closed all day. So yeah.
How much money can she make?
$50 a video to ruin your life.
That's a thing.
Is it really worth it is,
I think she, she might be pushing a
little too hard at this point. I heard,
cause I think she's gotten a few out.
She's like,
I gotta get a few more out
in their bodies. Like, um,
it's going to be a little extra on
the end of this one that sounded like
she's all winded.
My work here is done.
Can you hear that
tailbone?
Oh God.
It's like Rodenbach Lee.
Yuck.
I mean, how much could
she make? Seriously?
I don't even $50 a video dude in
this like, well no, because there's,
there's gotta be multiple,
you know, viewers, guys that,
do you think they're paying,
you don't think they're paying $50 each?
It's a subscriber based.
I don't know.
I'm trying to guess like to figure out
like if she's putting this up somewhere
and she's obviously
speaking to an audience,
a group of people that are used
to coming there, maybe they pay,
I don't know, $10, $20 each.
The demand to put out content.
I mean,
she's really gotta be farting every day,
every other day.
I'm rethinking being married
to you if you're doing this.
Now I'm thinking maybe this is a good
idea. I'm thinking of the potential.
What's the pros? Just the sheer volume.
Yeah. Yeah. As long as we can get a,
you know, a decent, uh,
cause you're just the, uh,
the upfront costs are just
the food to make the fart. No,
what makes me far too, so there's
the thing is no trial and error.
40 years of doing this. I mean,
I've been in this game long enough.
I know it works for me. What are you
want to call the site fart mistress.
Oh, that's probably taken.
I'm sure I wanted to look
Fart,
mess,
stress 40 cause then then I
combined like the mill genre.
Oh yeah. No, I mean wet
fart mistress.
Did you mean fart mistress?
Mistress fart porn two mistresses,
but there's not fart mistress.com is
what I'm saying. Far Mres 40 yeah,
cause then it combines taken and
the FARC genre together. Right.
I think that's smart marketing
Tris,
the farting MILF.
That's another one
from a marketing standpoint that no,
I typed it in as a URL.
No results for fart
mistresses. Yeah. Hello? Yeah.
Buy It up now.
Well now someone's going to buy it.
I believe we hadn't buyers for mistress.
Bart mistress is here
now. How much content do I have to
put out? Is it once a week or daily?
Like how are these porn sites
work? Tell me. I don't know.
I don't know how that stuff works.
Oh sure. I don't know how the
uploading content you ask, you ask our
friend Yoshi, he knows all that stuff.
But I mean to keep my
subscribers engaged and happy,
I would think of at least a couple of week
and then I had a tweet,
the videos and, but then you're
just giving it away for free. Right?
All tastes see the whole thing.
Well that's the thing that the teaser
is the whole show pretty much. I mean,
a Fart is humble. If we second could be,
the teaser could be like, oh guys, ah,
some big ones coming.
That's what I worry about in that genre.
Is it so limited creatively?
Like how many set up?
Why don't we get more creative
with it? But I mean, it's like, oh,
I have to Fart so bad.
Ah,
like we need to really think of a way
to reinvent the Fart, Mr Shaundra.
That's true. I mean, what
if it's an accidental thing?
Like we set up these scenarios where like,
I'm at jury duty and then I'm like,
oh my God, Tom, I have to Fart so
bad. I'm, I'm afraid to let it out.
And you're like, just let it out
and like I fart in public and stuff.
Could that be a genre? Could be
zone, right? Yeah, of course.
What about the car fart where you,
it's like a hot one and then you leave,
you come back. It's still
there. That kind of stuff.
So you're getting more creative about
done this other pole thing is that as
you're doing that out there in the world,
you know that a bunch of guys
are enjoying it. You know,
can't look when you squeeze it all guests.
He's so gross. He's still
worst. He is not the way.
He's so gross like a granddad.
Oh my God. Just all guests. I'm coming up.
Duda got some coming up.
Have you been doing your exercise
every day?
I love the way Andy 50 how's it going,
rob?
Rob,
how's your 50 50 50 times
now? You get the penis out. Yeah,
you pull the skin. A lot of people.
Then there was certain census circumstance
with the skin and you get the oil in
the hand and you're up 10 called
ladies do rob, Rob, rob, rob,
especially on the Klan Penis
rubbed them 50 times. Rus.
Okay, because you met them
strong and not sensitive.
Oh, he's so gross. 50
time. Once one, uh, Rice.
I protect site.
If your town from 50 time
bet 50 times dow. Why?
Okay.
How often am I doing this?
You have to do every day until
you can control every day.
Everyday. Just Jack Your Dick. 300
times. That's what he's been doing.
That's why he's the expert.
The Dick Jacket.
When an asshole is the dig.
Jackie, just a poker room.
I love that you call him just a pervert.
Well that's what all these clowns
are. No here, like I rubbed my deck.
Maybe I can teach to other people.
Yeah,
he is so nasty. I hate his hand. Rap, rap,
rap, rap. The rap. Will you try it once?
Just try it. Try it. It's 300 strokes
total, right? Yeah, I'll try it.
You go down and then you
had to pull the it. He says,
some people want circumstance. He's
all for it. But I mean, yeah, yeah.
50 50, 50, 50. It's just down, down,
down. It's not down back. You know
what I'm saying? Right. So you're just,
he's trying to get your,
you're Ding Dong less sensitive
is throw up from coming so hard.
He is so nasty.
I don't know. I seriously, okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. What'd you rather
kiss? Shacks. Tutsis.
And we saw it look like we saw
what shacks, feet look like.
Okay, now you've got to bring it up. You
can't do more. And you got to bring it up,
man. We did in the last episode, his feet.
If you're listening to
this just on the podcast,
please Google shacks, feet
your foot, you're going to die.
I mean, it doesn't even look human. The
poor guys been playing for his whole life.
His feet are just mangled.
A shot
that's been nasty.
Uh,
kiss that,
kiss that policy,
or every time you're masturbating,
you got to have the Chinese guy
coaching you and he's like, rub,
rub, rub. And then you
play the audio of him.
Jackie leaning as you ejaculate.
Every time I Jack off
You have him coaching you
and then when you come he goes with you.
He comes with you to the hotel rooms.
Like when you're on the road, it rob, rob,
every time you do your 50
50 fifties he's coaching,
he's coaching you from the
cherries. Like Tom, rob, rob,
right.
I think I would deal with it. I think
it was fine. I think I don't mind it.
I don't mind it. I think I liked
that he's an expert and I'd be like,
am I doing it right?
And I'd like to have like a little
little expert opinion in there.
I think I'd be into it. I like it. You're
sick. I like it. I think, I think he'd be,
he'd be like, you forgot the
left side. I was like, Oh
yeah, I forgot. He's like Tom,
he's rob, Rob, rob. He's like
a trainer that goes, uh hey,
I saw you put your knees down, get
back up there. Right. You know,
so you definitely wouldn't come
fast because he know. Yeah.
Like I would have major control.
You know what? Come to think of it.
He should be like a concierge service.
Like he,
you should come to your house and teach
you how to Rob Rob, because I lie,
you won't come. I think it would
be mildly difficult to stay hard
if he's sitting there looking at you
like rob and you're like, um, dude, why?
I can't really get it up right now. I
can't believe you feel that way. Yeah.
I think I would have a little bit of
difficulty. Terrible. Yeah. The shot.
I would take checks,
but any day,
especially on the penis now,
would you rather have sex with him?
No other option or you have to put shocks,
whole foot in your coochie he's
done. I mean, it would hurt,
but I'd find a way why I squeezed
a person out of there. I don't,
why would you do that over that? Because
that guy is so fucking gross. Dude.
The Chinese case. The worst.
That's the worst. Yeah. He's,
he's a nasty pervert. He really
is. Nasty program. You're so,
and that guy at all.
How about Stevens to goal or him?
Steven Seagal. Really?
He's not that repugnant,
sweaty, fat, older guy. He's not that
bad. I mean, he's got that silly hair,
but that's, you know, that's nothing.
He's probably way more annoying.
I have to listen to him talk
about himself all day soon.
I am the king of Improv for you.
You want to deal with that?
Yeah. So you all about sex.
You think that guy's annoying about
sex the moment you choose to call,
he's going to be like, I've made more
girls come in the last hundred and 20
even imagine and then
he'll start doing like,
wait a minute, let me,
hold on. Let me just, uh,
let me talk to you. A pussy
food is nasty. It's both nasty,
but I think they're amazing guys.
Much more charming.
Why is he the grossest I just,
I'm not attracted to him at all.
I just think he's Rose Rose.
I don't like his,
I actually can't believe you find
him grosser than say, Oh yeah.
Really know why. I think because the old
Chinese guy could be like my granddad.
I feel like he's too old.
He's not that old.
He's like your sweet old Chinese grandad.
I don't like him.
He's too nasty to talking.
My jacket is deg and stuff.
I don't want to hear that dad.
Hey, you got to tell you something.
I'm Pauley and I'm bi.
I'm poly and I'm by one of my
favorite moments of the shell.
Was that
alright?
Baton from both angles. All right, so
email in Molly
and I'm by audio issue with the podcast.
Hey Hitler.
I've noticed in the past few episodes
that every time you say that you are
playing a clip of someone
puking or farting,
I never actually hear
someone puking or farting,
but I'm even an even more obnoxious sound
that turns out to be Christina's voice.
It's a complete turnoff for me
and I'm sure it is for others.
Also after glass and through the Internet
for hours trying to troubleshoot,
I came across a webpage dedicated
to this type of disturbing problem.
It said that this issue is actually stems
from a complete lack of personality is
causing the audio interference
in parentheses. Christina.
This makes perfect sense.
As Christina's personality is as dry
as an old lady's vaccine in the Mojave
desert,
I suggest adding more of Tom's refreshing
and sweet personality as well as his
water champs skills to come patch,
combat,
Christina's obnoxious and
embarrassing personality.
Please fuck my triple d slot wife
Kristen, Kansas. Well, Chris from Kansas,
you can suck my tits. My ass. Yeah,
tell him all about it. Well, I
mean this is silly. This is silly.
I think it's silly. Yeah, the whole
thing is silly. I'm personality champ.
I'm the world champ.
Everybody knows. Oh, come on.
Who brought the water to you today
before the show? And by the way,
you think you haven't even cracked
your syrup. And that's true.
Cause you're so fucking
babe,
baby. No, I fucking hate that.
Oh No, I'm not going to listen.
I know that you've done it.
You push a button again.
I just fucking saw you not listening.
All right,
we're done.
You think I was born yesterday?
We're done. I'm not putting
my headphones on. Why?
Cause I know you got some nasty Shillay
now. No, I don't. I don't. I promise.
I promise.
Let me see your hands.
You just push something cause I'm
setting up the next thing to play.
I have to play something else.
Jean,
may I go ahead. Okay. So we had a, Oh,
this lady, um, that was in the, the uh,
UK lady who tried to make a trustee yet.
Here I'll show the clip and then I'll,
okay.
Ladies standing there.
She uses her hairdryer as
a make believe cause and,
but Mike's going now all
up and down the road.
It hard to stop.
How many cigarettes did you smoke when
you describe her for our listeners?
And um,
this woman I can be related to this is
also very eastern European look. Yeah.
Uh, not good teeth, soggy mushy measures.
And they're mashed into a tube top,
which when you got big hangers
you can not wear a two.
Is that a good look up the table for you?
Yeah,
I mean there's a lot going on though.
You're leaving a lot off. You do it. Well,
I mean it's a bit of a weathered look.
Haggard full life. I prefer. Um,
yeah, there's, I mean if you were
to just crop out everything else,
you could definitely make this a Zim.
Well,
how well do you think she they are?
I think they are much
younger than they look.
I worry that they are like 55.
They don't look good.
They have been
zippy Dan to route. She's been
riding it hard. Drinking hard.
So what she does
bikes and costs.
Well I do love shit like this though.
So she holds out a hairdryer.
Hilarious.
And it has the effect of making
these cars slow down. I love it.
You don't on our street but
going all up and down the road.
No. Yeah. And those all up them them the
road. Those chompers are something else.
And I'm just listening to the voice.
Cool.
Simply by picking up on it though.
I have never seen so many
people's brake lights go on.
And only chase is a hair dryer
lover. I love vigilante shit like
this. What do you think of that?
I think we have l one l two l three and
I'm going to score them. Five, five, five,
five, five, five, five,
five, five, five, five
goes, Eh, look like artifacts. Yeah.
Those look like if you were in a museum
that you like, we discovered these.
They're over 60,000 years old.
Paleolithic woman.
She reminds me of those Gypsies.
We used to watch a lot gypsy's age
poorly as well. She might be gypsy. Yeah,
actually. Yeah, that would
make more sense. Definitely.
Take a look at here I am calling
her. She over and over. So rude.
The thing is is that you know you're on
television and you think you wouldn't
wear or the tube top, mashed your tits
down. No makeup, like just clean up.
All of that could traps her shoulders.
She's got tribes like yours,
dude, hitting the old heck squat.
If they don't like it.
I live here.
My friends live here.
My friends children live here and if
we can't be safe in around streets,
how the hell are we going to
be safe in the world? Right?
Yeah. Good point. I do like her
method. What about what's what's
happening behind her? The sale rack
there? Yeah. It's like a yard sale.
Oh Man.
She's like 41 years old,
right?
I'm 38 this year.
What if she was that young?
She could be.
Sometimes these folks don't age
very well. Yeah. They, they live,
live on a diet of like wonder bread.
Real hot Cheetos and
Mario. We'll see. Yeah,
we'll see. Do you prefer basement? Hey,
should I go to take a hot Cheetos and
Takis? And that's what she's eight.
Do you want her to here at three or
four? Whatever you want gene. Well,
it's 10 after two. So what do you think?
Why I need to take a swim after this,
but as long as I can do that.
Okay. Right, sure. Um, okay,
so keep talking. Uh, I like her initiative
with doing this with a hairdryer.
I feel like we need to do this on our
street because so many assholes just
whoosh whiz by and we live in the burbs.
Man. You shouldn't be doing that shit.
There's kids on bikes.
Yeah.
You feel me?
You know?
No, I have relatives that
look this bad. Definitely.
I got a couple right now that look
like that. That's just hard to have.
I have some rough living relatives.
Yeah. But that's hard living.
No south of the border.
Right, right. Yeah.
No dentistry or medical
care. No access to it. Yeah.
Yeah. She's not doing Pilati use twice
a week, stick and do primal diet,
stuff like that. Yeah. I like
your sounds. I do yet. Yeah.
Wow. Wow. Wow.
Yeah.
You know how it is caused
bikes going by you?
My goodness. Yeah. Um, yeah.
One of my favorite
things that I saw on Instagram,
I think it was,
was it that Scotty Pippin, um, page.
Anyways,
I think that who posted this,
this dude posted this video of,
it's kind of like that. Um,
what's it called when like the,
like the, the court shows, you
know, we're like, they confessed,
the let the TV judge decide
everything in Spanish.
And this one was just out radius,
but it's all in Spanish. But just to
highlight that somebody said this on TV.
Okay.
So
you're fine.
So this lady with a studio
audience is telling the judge, um,
he told us to uncover our backsides
and as we were still wearing those
transparent ropes. Okay. Um,
I was the fourth one down,
right? Yeah. Okay. Yes.
[inaudible]
I started hearing heavy breathing.
No, you don't know him.
He will be in Toronto.
Weird moaning behind.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
and then out of nowhere I feel
someone's tongue liking my bud.
Bye.
Amy.
I tried to hit him, but he grabbed me
and said I was ruining the ritual. Oh
yeah. Basically just put your hand
under the [inaudible] may wow know.
So this guy told me that he
was going to heal me, right?
Oh yeah.
No
bye. [inaudible] se it'll
say, yeah, of course.
So she's saying that like,
I was supposed to let this guy lick me
on the ass and that was supposed to seal
the deal.
Like on the ritual.
Is there any factors in your practice?
It does it, yeah. So those guys,
is that the same saying in Spanish
tossing salad and that this is,
why would they call that?
Is there a route?
Praise. Uh, I think she said
one here. She said it's okay.
I think I meant that.
That'd be so negative that the,
I dunno, the, the black kiss,
is that what she's saying? I don't
know. I think that's what she said.
That's what it sounds.
He's the guy.
Yum.
You know,
either yellow [inaudible]
El [inaudible] son.
So,
oh my,
this guy who looks like a
quirky spiritual guy. Right?
Like you don't see him being like at
the top of a mountain and be like, yeah,
let's spend a month here. Don't talk.
So he has this, he's bald, he's older,
he's got this weird white
shirt that has like no collar.
Right?
Like,
and he's telling that the court now
that dogs and cats heal themselves with
their tongues, Jesus cured a
blind man with his saliva. Yeah.
I never read that one, Gary. I know.
Why the anus.
Why?
Because all the bad stuff comes from
their true. True. Okay. Don't just,
I get as flat
well, lot. No.
So he spits on their cans.
It, why did you show that?
Is it upsetting?
Yeah. I feel like so many things on
your mom's house. It never phased me.
That's like one of those things
and it cause it's a holy man and he's
taking advantage of people's religion.
Well, he's not taking advantage of
anyone. He's feeling people. I hate that.
I hate that people trust him. It's so
sad. Yes. Thanks for bumming me out. Well,
maybe you'd want it to feel a little.
Okay.
That's what I feel. All right. I
like that these people were like,
this is charge and they're like, okay,
pull your pants down. Okay, now spread
your cheeks. Gotcha. Like what
don't you be like, fuck you.
I'm not pulling my pants down.
Crazy train.
I'm going to lick your ass for a
minute and make you feel better. Right,
but what you wouldn't protest at
that level. Let me ask you this.
I kind of feel like this is actually a
great evidence for your honor's pace in
getting you to kiss my,
give me the black.
Yes is a holy man's ploy
cleans on the impurity.
US.
As you can see,
this very spiritual man has cured many
people by spitting in the healthiest of
places.
And I feel
that
counsel would best serve
me back cleaning my bed.
Uh,
dirty evil.
Oh,
I think we should take you to a yoga
class so that you can learn to lick your
own butt hole. Okay. That is not what I
signed up for. It was not what I want.
Can I just take a rag on a stick and wet
it and then mash it against your butt
hole? I'd be like, that's my
tongue. No, that's the same
thing. It's the same thing.
It's the same thing. What's, what's
Mario saying? Maria just said,
I challenge you and Bert
to a water challenge.
Okay. I will win. And if
you want a bigger challenge,
we can do a pull up, push up, post
Tito's challenge and I'll still win.
Love you. Hm. Well first of all, the
water challenge wouldn't be with him.
It'd be with you and me. That's the,
she's not getting it. She doesn't get,
she doesn't understand that. No. Would
you want to take her up on that challenge?
No, because I've never been a
showboat or like you are, will you?
You guzzle a gallon and then own the
water champ. It's not about that.
It's about hydrating constantly throughout
the day so that I don't need to binge.
I understand. I'm a consistent, you're,
you're, you're just, you're jumping ahead.
Would you want to have a
day long water challenge?
I don't need the challenge. I know
exactly who I am and I am the true champ.
You don't want to compete in this.
Why would I? Okay. To be the wind.
What's the point to say who
drinks the most or who drinks,
who drinks the most in a day? Not
a binge moment in a day. Okay,
but that's the thing. It's like
the, you're going to binge,
you're going to push yourself day than
you normally do. I can drink it all day.
Do you want to prove that you're the water
champ by partaking in the competition
with Maria or with you? With the two
of us. So it's a threeway competition.
What does, but what does she have to,
she doesn't have anything to do with it.
She's not a part of this thing.
She's saying that she's the water
champion and the and wants to dethrone us.
I don't want to do this now.
Why? Why? Why would I want,
I don't like doing
contests like you and Bert.
I don't like putting myself through
suffering for the point of what? No,
I don't like it. I know why.
I know in my heart who I am.
I don't need to fucking compete.
No. In my heart who I am,
I already know that I am the champion.
Why would I even need to compete?
Demean myself to base myself to
compete with fucking peasants.
You and Maria are jokes. You guys are
fucking, you're not even in my league.
Why would I compete with a
dilettante drinkers? Okay.
You guys are fucking Sunday drinkers,
but this thing, I'll know this.
When you say things like that,
you can back it up with what you do.
That's the whole point. Yeah.
I've, I've, I know I'm hydrated.
The doctor says I'm perfect. Everything's
perfect. I've been to a urologist, they,
the guy told me to stop drinking
so much so you won't take place.
Take Part in the competition?
No, I don't believe,
I don't like doing stuff like that. That's
a fucking waste of my time. Okay. Um,
I would like to accept Maria's challenge
for the water drinking competition.
Oh my God. What? When are you going
to do this? Tomorrow. Okay. Okay.
Or I dunno, the next day. Wait, what?
Is that so weird to you? I mean, no,
it just sounds like torture because you
guys are just going to gorge and drink
too much and it's going to be miserable.
I don't have that kind of time
right now. I got to do stuff, man.
You don't have that kind of thing. No,
I'm busy the next two weeks, you know,
shooting my special, go to
San Francisco. All right.
I had to fucking go do shit tomorrow.
I'll have time to, if I can do this. Yeah.
But you know,
you realize you're not allowed.
Like when you say that
you won't participate,
you're not allowed to be part
of the conversation. Great.
But I mean, you're no longer even allowed
to call yourself the water champion.
That's fine. I know in my heart who
I am. I'm secure with who I am. Yeah.
Big l with what you are. It's
fine. So be it. So be it.
You guys have, I'm great at this. I
don't need to compete. It's a silly,
this is childish. I'm, I'm
an adult. Your children.
Okay. All right. Um,
speaking of great fun things. My, uh,
two sentences and I'm not
sure it wasn't the same,
but this is a major league baseball
player reading his own mother's jokes
to, uh, to uh, uh,
a teammate of his and
the teammates reaction
is almost unbelievable.
It actually feels like
top dog is in the room.
It's Monday.
We're going to do mom joke,
Phillips and will Smith
has a lot of corny jokes.
So we're going to tell a few
to Mr Breath. Philip. Sarah,
see if we can't get them to laugh.
So is there his mother's jokes? Okay.
Why did the stadium get hot after
the game? Because it was hot.
Just like my dance left.
Look at that guys lap
because he fucking with him.
I don't know.
I don't know. I think they're both, I
think they're both, it's pretty funny.
I think this guy is,
is questionable up top,
you know? I don't think he's a
all there. The guy on the left.
Yeah. I think he's got
real problems. Like maybe,
maybe he used to play football before
he played baseball and that kind of
problem.
Yeah. That's so good. How'd
you make an egg roll there?
Push it
like he's really,
he thinks that's really funny.
You think so? I think he knows that one's
corny. I think he does, but he's like,
oh my gosh,
this is good
money.
No, it's not pleasant. The bicycle fall
over because they didn't have a peg.
I was too tired. Your tires
to get that way. I get it.
I think he's, I think he's
really liked this touched.
Yeah. A little bit. Sweet guy.
But you know, were tarred. He got
all the genes to play a sport.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then
to think about anything else.
What are the ducks out of the bars?
Dinner Plaque and put it on my bill.
I'm like, God, I really landed very
good. I like that one. Oh my God,
they're both laughing at that.
Look at him. Look at him.
Oh my gosh. Oh my God.
What's happening here?
Oh Man. Oh, he really thinks it's funny.
Got It. Oh, got
really thinks it's funny. I like, is it,
it made me that there's so
much more innocent than we are.
Like they'd probably don't sit
here and talk about, you know,
farting and fist fucking coming
all day long a week segments.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
These guys don't talk about
the horrible things we do.
They must be not as desensitized.
Yeah. Is that what's going on?
Uh, yeah. I mean this guy is probably
a really sweet guy and uh, yeah,
he's probably,
I think it has a lot to do with the
kindness of his heart is being nice. Yeah.
I remember reading these jokes off a
popsicle sticks when I was a child and I
was, I still was like Wah, Wah. Like
I never thought they were funny.
It's an intelligence factor. It
is. You think so? Of course. Yeah,
of course it is. I don't
know. Um, or you know,
intelligence as in the real
world experience. Yeah.
Miss Street savvy. You know,
he's not super smart.
He might be,
I mean
this is for, what does the duck say to the
bartender? Oh my God. Put It on my right
bill. Right. That's what I mean.
Put It on my bill is
am I bill? Okay, so you're
like, all right, good laugh.
But then you really, I mean,
come on.
He can't keep it together.
I mean that's,
I wish I were that easily
amused. Dumb. Broad. Yeah. Yeah,
me too.
Right. That'd be so much
easier. Watch sitcoms everyday.
We can watch friends and think
it was the best show ever. Amen.
You see what Ross did?
It was so funny he did that
hand gesture and saying, okay,
fund will Smith and the snow will Smith.
That's you put first fresh prince.
He doesn't get it.
He doesn't get it
right.
He's not that much. Huh? Dude, this guy.
Yeah, he's been hit with a ball in
the head with a bat. Maybe a couple of
what of his story is like,
uh,
this guy and when he was 15
was beaten relentlessly. Yeah.
Is that brain damage?
Somehow he was able to maintain
his ability to play baseball.
I was in a coma. He's in now
we're shitting on him. Yeah.
How do you know if you're in
front of a Polish firing squad?
That's true. The guns
are faced. If the, uh,
your Dad die,
Dad, dad, do you not understand
how these folks work?
You're not supposed to actually try
to answer them the best day ever.
It was such a good day.
Yeah.
And we got them again here when I had
them in studio guy. I loved those blinds.
It was so weird to me that they
lacked the hard, it's weird to me too,
that she laughed. She laughed that
hard. Well, I think your mom, I mean,
you have to forgive her because she's
working on a second language thing and
yeah, that's really a
cultural humor. Yeah.
But I guess this is like
when certain people,
like certain comedians that you're
like, that is so not on my radar. Yeah.
Finding and you're like, why do you,
why are people laughing? I don't,
I don't get it. Jane, you remember
this should be a roll call last week.
I was trying to forget that. My
name is Cindy. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I like donuts. Yeah. Sweet. Yeah. Neat.
Yeah,
so shove my hand in my ass in about it.
I was hired two years ago at a large
biotechnology seed corn company and we had
a toned down version of the boy,
a cult chant before taking the job.
I spent seven months in Afghanistan
getting shot at sometimes shooting back,
sleeping and jacking off when again,
when it came to my turn in the
Sheboygan ceremonial ceremonial circle,
I was zoning out and I froze and yell,
Hey,
my name is Andrew. Clap,
clap, and I killed a man.
It gets super quiet and they canceled
the rest of the Ori till lunch.
I do appreciate not having to attend
these dog shit, retard festivals anymore.
I to talk to HR a couple of times
after that. I appreciate it, dude.
I ain't tight. Thanks Mommy. Andrew,
do you realize that that dude's Improv
in that moment ended their entire
orientation that's effective?
And do you realize that? I mean,
cause that's an unconscious thing that
should be [inaudible] experience was so
traumatic that it unconsciously
led him to think of his war days.
Do you know what I mean? When he's like,
there's nothing worse than this. Oh wait,
Afghanistan. And also the fact that
it's, um, chant like, you know,
so you go to the same beat rhythm,
so your brain goes into that kind
of stream of consciousness. Yeah.
And then he was like, what can I say
about myself? I killed a guy anyway.
Yeah. They're like, from my
group stops. And then hands drew,
are you guys gonna clap again? And they're
like, oh, because you realize that some,
someone there could have,
could have thought also that,
uh, that was a confession.
Like he killed a civilian. Oh,
right. Like I killed my roommate.
What? Thank God. His body. Yeah.
Oh, oh. Oh Lord. Yeah. Wow.
I'm sure Afghanistan was better than this
fucking shit. Thanks for your service,
Andrew. And thanks for writing in.
That is an amazing story. Actually.
This Dad Boehner thing came in that,
um, I actually find it to be more,
it's one of these interesting, you
know, sometimes you're like, yeah,
that's pretty cool. It's, I don't
know if you've seen this yet or not,
but this is a dad boner.
Wait a minute. This isn't the
right place to skip a rock, dude.
He'll never go in and look at that.
Perfect skipping rocks.
Wow.
Oh, that's cool. Shit. Yeah.
So he went to skip the rock and I guess
there's a bunch of ice on this lake.
Yeah. And then it, the pitch
turned into that. That's crazy.
I didn't, you know, as possible. Neither
did I. It's really cool. Skipping rocks.
No,
this is awesome.
But I understand it.
Wow.
But again, is exciting. I'd feel the
same way. Unwarranted. Beautiful.
Wherever they are. Yeah.
It looks nice. Yeah.
Yes. You're doing right. Bombs away.
Big One.
His face is priceless.
I love this.
This is awesome.
We're getting away to a story out of this.
I think it's really great actually.
Yeah. That's fun. Yeah. Make Fun of that.
Boner on that one. No, that
must be a perfect thing.
Like the acoustics of the
mountains and the ice.
It's special. It's pretty cool, man.
Yeah. I liked his face. Yeah. Little Kid.
Open face. Oh, he was so happy.
Oh. Oh. Oh. 50 Times.
50 Times. Oh, so excited.
Sometimes there's just
exciting things that happened.
All right,
here we go.
This one's crazy.
Three years.
See, this doesn't add up. This
doesn't make sense. A mental illness.
Here we go.
I mean, that's for driving on a
bridge. A little shrouds Canada.
Ow. Ow. Ow. Ow.
Ow. Oh, ow.
Yeah.
Oh,
this road towels.
okay.
That's so crazy. That's one of my
favorite things we've ever discovered. Oh.
Oh. Oh. I wonder. I wish I could
know the story. That's one of those.
Thanks. Yeah. I wish I could
know why. Why the excitement?
I just don't get it. It
is mental illness, right?
It feels like it. Yeah. It's
gotta be craziness. Yeah.
It feels like we're trying to
find this, uh, is this the, um,
pronouns song I was trying to send them.
Hey. Hi. How are you? What's
your name? What's Your Pronoun?
That's a definitely.
Hey,
hey. Hi. How are you? What's your
name? What's Your Pronoun? How are you?
Yeah, but since I heard Jen talking
shit about me at the bar last night,
the one I thought it was here.
Yeah,
there's so many options.
Then the Thursday through them
in the time jet in there, but
hey. Hi. How are you? What's your
name? What's Your Pronoun? Them.
They just wanted to confirm what's,
what's your pronoun? What's,
what's your Pronoun Ze Zer.
What's your product
man?
Fuck right now.
Ah.
Oh
Wow.
This reminds me of,
that's Bj boy butter by a San Francisco
in the 90s this is exactly what we saw.
Some wild shit. You told
me once that you saw. Yes,
there guys fucking in the streets.
Just real crazy,
but fucking each other all the time.
Any two people fucking in the streets.
It's crazy,
but back then I feel like SF was way
gay or and and wackier and more fun.
Yeah. Now it's, yeah, upstairs
like us to Douche bags,
going to whole foods with their kids.
It's a little different now that
I don't love San Francisco guys.
I'm not saying that,
but it's just culturally very
different since the dot commerce came.
There's people like us now.
It's not the Weirdo.
They used to be a real beacon for weird
beards. It was really fucking far out.
It was really fun. Oh, I had the
bed. We had the best time. I mean,
we just get on those Muni buses,
get high smoke, drink beer,
walk around Haight street.
See fucking weird shit.
You steers to be a guy that dressed up
like Sherlock Holmes under the freeway
and people would just be like,
what's up Sherlock?
Like he would just yell hi
Sherlock. And he was, you know,
there was a guy in a pink units hard on
a fucking unicycle that was on Haight
street all the time. Just the pink guy. I
used to see him all the time. Woo Hoo, go,
whew. I mean just, and they're
always there. Just straight, weird,
weird, all kinds of weird shit. Now it's,
I don't know whether the Weirdos
Weirdos are in Portland now, I think.
I think Portland's the New San Francisco.
See there's a lot of Weirdos in Portland.
Yeah,
they all kind of went for and there's
a pride about it, which is interesting,
which is awesome. Yeah.
Fucking where they're at.
I just pulled up this page thinking,
you know,
there's 400 episodes in
neuro and we found this.
Oh Mom.
Yeah,
that was great.
That's from like a special edition
episode of cops where they did a,
I mean obviously the air on a regular
episode that they put it on like a best of
type of cops tape and it was a
random youtube fine going away.
It's gone. Shut up. Yeah,
it's not there anymore.
I mean we were randomly watching
it and then we were like, wait,
what did that guy just said it doesn't
he sound like say my mom's house and
we're, you know, it's like the
early days of your mom's house.
Like how perfect is it that it's like a
weird thing cause we like playing weird
segment audio and this guy's like,
oh mom,
my mom's house.
And then our first sponsor of this show
with stamps.com and then this guy says,
so then we would be like, this episode
is brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com and then if we win,
we want you to use our,
our website shop through the
Amazon banner. Check out the clips,
see where you can see us live.
Go to our web.
I'm Bob,
I'm a Martian
as the websites ww,
the best.
It's not in, this is the cops with
him because when they're like,
how are you doing today, sir? Uh,
what, what you doing out here?
Um,
mom,
sorry. Okay, go ahead and give me that
license in a registration for you.
And then he goes, uh, you
have, uh, you have, uh,
anything to drink today
while you're sitting down.
You're gonna have anything to drink.
I'm Bob [inaudible], I'm a Marshall. I'd
go ahead and do me a favor. Turn off
that car. Just step out for a second.
Like that's the guy stays like,
so like treats him like he's actually
speaking English back to like a toddler.
Me a favor.
Go ahead and turn that off.
And the step out for me and they're look
like that this guy is definitely coming
with, that's gotta be the
hardest part of law enforcement,
which is the majority of law
enforcement. You're just like, sir, sir,
could you step out of the car?
Just be normal.
Like the guy actually said
something. Sure. So battling,
you have the registration,
the registration on you right now?
Yeah, it's lent. Um,
anyways, it's been crazy.
I tell people this at live shows,
I say it all the time when they go,
you know, I listen to the podcast,
I love it. And that's, you know,
that's why they come out.
This is the most fun thing we do is
do this podcast because it's really,
it really is all the stupid shit that
you and I have enjoyed over the years.
And it's all about silly and it's great
because we come in here and we see all
the world, everything is sealed off and
it's just talking about stuff we really,
truly care about new way.
Genuinely. I want to say, uh,
we do appreciate everybody
that listens to the show,
downloads the show and
tells us that they enjoy it.
The help site all the time. It sounds
like really goofy to say almost, right?
But people are like, oh, it
helps me get through my work day,
or it helps us a good distraction
from whatever mundane thing I'm doing.
You know, I never, we never
expected anybody would say
that. And I think it's, uh,
it's very cool that
people enjoy it like that.
It overwhelms me at times when we do
the show live or I go do standup and all
the mommies show up and you're just like,
this is crazy crazy.
This started just out of us talking
about farts and shit like that that we
normally would talk about and to think
that it's really touched the lives of so
many people. So silly. The
House that far it's built.
So anyways, we're gonna, you know, there's
no, there's no sign of us down with this.
Um, we're going to be having, like
I said, we've had guests lately.
We're bringing some, we have guests
lined up coming up, some episodes,
we'll have them, some won't,
but there's, you know,
it's one of the most fun things we do.
So there's no way we would slip,
slow down or stop doing this
400 and hopefully 4,000 more.
Um,
that's it man.
Oh, um, I don't know.
We were wanting to do a glossary
of terms from your mind.
Somebody start that already. I don't
know. But if I know the Facebook page,
you guys do that,
can someone started glossary or maybe a
Wikipedia page of all the terms are some
localized place that fans can go,
you know,
there's gotta be someone who's
in charge of all of these things.
There you go. And a, I know we said
it at the top, but obviously, uh,
go to thousand ranch.com for tickets
to the San Francisco shows and uh,
the link for Christina Seattle special
taping that's coming up in just a couple
of weeks. And, um, I announced
a bunch of dates. You,
you already know that we
announced that, but, uh,
there at Thomson [inaudible] dot com so
go there and of course, your mom's house,
podcast.com. That's it for us
this week. Gene. Anything else?
No, I think that's it.
Yeah. Thank you guys.
I just want to say thanks to everybody
for listening and supporting this and,
and, and, uh, I hope everybody's
genes stay tight and high as minor.
I wore my highest, highest pair for
this episode. Did you see? Yeah.
Look how tight these are.
Was it really a tight,
nice job. This is a doctor,
but trumpet Buy Bananas. Um, here it is.
Thank you guys for making 400.
So fun to Fart hundred. Yeah,
that's a good one. That's,
that's, that's, that's, that's
a good one. That's got that.
Yup.
Yup. That's a good one. That's, that's,
that's, that's, that's a good one.
All
right.